[Music]
hey everybody Colonel Brian here with
another clueless gamer today we've got a
a big one I'm told the highly
anticipated overwatch this is huge this
is an epic game so I got two of the
stars of the most epic show on
television Game of Thrones to play with
me please welcome my best friends as of
four minutes ago Peter Dinklage Lena
Headey thank you so much for being here
do you guys play video games I don't but
I'm ready and you beat it is this for
there was only one Iron Throne
so I took it this is in fact a toilet
yeah makes it functional this is my
toilet from my home he lets this grow
and this just broke and yeah we're just
ripping apart the Iron Throne as we go
look at that there you go
yeah this is really no expense was
spared these are made of starbursts they
put some shoe polish on it this controls
the toilet it's like a Japanese I love
those you walk into the bathroom yeah
and they open you don't even touch
anything but you know what's creepy I
was in a hotel recently and it had that
and the toilet opens every time you walk
past it yeah and every time I walk by
the toilet
coming in to get the flush the devil
plug and then it closes Sally Lake might
as well - hey by the way do you like our
set no expense was spared
very sexy isn't it yeah very sensual
it's being inside of a vagina
can you save that no you just did and
you know what this is gold come on in
Boy tell us about the game yeah so over
watch this is why I called you in
you were great as the dad and family
time yeah possibilities
you've got your launches oh my god he's
got the legs of like a pigeon Lena come
we've got this guy junk rat Joey like
junk
he is the power of low self-esteem Rico
oh Lord
somebody smash this that's kind of cool
with Lucio oh look at that
somebody's on rollerblades yeah his only
enemy is an uneven surface he can
accomplish anything but oh this is some
slate gravel in the road I can't help
you okay I like him yes he's got nice
balls yeah MC Hammer backup dancer at
one point so the idea here is you guys
are going to be on separate teams you're
gonna be shooting each other trying to
take an objective or defend an objective
don't know what all right well I'm a
giant gorilla with a laser
really oh come on I just okay that
happened very quickly so Peter just show
you very quickly that's the character
stomp on your corpse yeah yeah and I got
four guns just kill him please kill him
he's getting very cocky inside I don't
know why oh yeah look at that up on a
platform up here you're coming at you
from above there hey wait I know I felt
mundane death a workplace accident took
you how to behave
where where where where where where
where what behind you
[Music]
you know my gun can't really shoot that
far yeah hiding behind balsa wood
shouldn't do anything
good old balsa wood impenetrable bust
you my lady
yeah so the next place we're gonna play
is the temple of Anubis it's in Egypt
you guys are each gonna have a team of
two other people with you what's the
objective the objective is there's maybe
some stuff going on but I know just you
just shoot people and we're in a
Moroccan restaurant why what's happening
I've got a hankerin TV that bumbo I'm in
is called celebrity behind that there's
Peter I'm gonna kill him yes I am time
to die
wait that was eliminated by Peter
you're out Lina sorry why did she leave
me there's four other people him
his range of facial expressions it's a
choking victim okay we're gonna do
something very special now at my request
all the women with shiny butts are gonna
fight each other don't shoot anyone just
enjoy their bodies can they make out
with each other is there a button where
they where they make out with each other
all the women no there's two we ask that
that be added to the game before can we
get that can we get that - can we get a
loop of the moaning
there you have it right there we just
watch Peter decimate Lena in this
competition Peter you are the winner
because it's Game of Thrones you will
now be presented with my head on a spike
by our george RR martin look-alike kind
of me
[Applause]
[Applause]
for more clueless gamer click here to
subscribe
oh come on sorry but you said click here
how do they know where to click oh
there's a thing on the thing that's done
in post